you are Steve Amanda Jones and your
gameplay designer at 2k Australia and
you Anthony but you're a writer give
books software and we're showing off
Borderlands be sequel and this is
Wilhelm turn around so we can see that
beautiful face yeah he is a boss in
Borderlands 2 but before that happened
he was a dude and this game is um the
origin dude story yeah it's the audience
about dudes it's just about where dudes
come from mommy boarded dudes come from
Borla pre-sequel is the answer so
basically yeah this takes place between
board lines one and two so he's a dude
who gets hired by a handsome jack two
stops and bad dudes from doing stuff on
the moon can I say dudes more often and
we're gonna go into a skill tree because
it actually ties into his character
growth into the cyborg we meet in
Borderlands 2 yep so his action skill is
the skill to summon his dudes wolf in
st. who are actually combat drones not
combat dudes
so wolf is the attack drone he'll go out
and attack your enemies st. as the
support drone he'll stay near you and
keep you alive which one loves you more
probably st. accurate yeah you guessed
correctly yep it's not that difficult so
let's have a look at his skill trees now
so we've got the hunter killer skill
tree here this one is um heavily focused
on upgrading wolf the attack drone you
can give wolf sort of extra attacks like
we've got venom bolts on the left here
which gives him the chance to fire
corrosive attack so it's really good
against armoured targets the next one
down is called laser-guided which is
really cool as well it basically allows
Willhelm to order wolf to attack certain
targets by using your action skill
button while looking at targets and then
st. sort of paints them with a laser and
then wolf will focuses attacks on that
target which is really cool so you can
sort of be this battlefield commander
and play this mini game of commanding
your drones and there's some other cool
skills down there when we hop down to
the capstone here which is called Omega
strike it she's really cool as well
basically Wolff will casually launch out
this missile strike so by that point
he's just doing ridiculous damage and
just a whole lot of fun
and moving on now we've got the
Dreadnought skill tree so this one has
some focus on st. the support drone and
you can basically buff up st. so he
heals you more he can like restore
shields to your friends and heal your
friends and cool stuff like that
this skill tree also has a lot of nice
defensive boosts for wellhome he
basically becomes really hard to kill
we're looking at one of his cool skills
here called termination protocols it
essentially replaces fight for your life
which is what happens when you go down
and rather than going down he gets
straight back up and can walk and shoot
and he shocks nearby enemies and then
when the timer runs out he goes power
core goes critical and he nukes himself
which can get second wind as well so
it's kind of cool it's like in that
movie about the killer robot yeah you've
got I've seen it it was called mr.
Magorium's wonder Emporium
yeah that's it that's why this skill is
named another cool one here which is the
capstone for dreadnought is called
overcharge when you summon Wolf's insane
Saint releases an energy wave which
gives awesome buffs to you and all your
friends really cool to pop at the start
of a boss fight um you can just do tons
of damage with it quickly really cool
and your friends will appreciate it if
you've got that one and the last skill
tree we've got here is the cyber
commandos skill tree which focuses on
the Wilhelm's the beginning of his
process of essentially becoming a
machine so as we go through the skills
once we get to the game-changer skills
such as power fist the next one just
here it actually replaces part of his
body when you pick up this skill so this
one in particular when we pick it up
you'll see his arm be replaced by a
robotic arm which gives it a special new
attack with the extra range explosive
damage really cool he's just sort of
change on his body there
I got shock absorbers as well which
replaces his legs allows them to shoot
while sprinting which is really cool
because no other Borderlands character
has been able to do that before and
having robot legs yep rubber legs
and lots of other cool skills in this
tree it's basically a mix of offensive
and defensive stuff cool one in there
that buffs his slam radius so it can
slam lots of dudes and the capstone here
is the vengeance cannon which when we
pick it up you'll see the vengeance
cannon appear on his back just there and
you may have heard it as we went down
actually but the further you get into
this tree the more robotic and nefarious
his voice becomes he starts off sounding
just like a dude and then gets processed
more and more and more the further you
get down and becomes more machine than
man machine then dude more machine
Edition where you would do but wish you
were not a dude then we'll hum is the
dude for you yeah so we're on the moon
cool so we're on the moon oh we we're
still looking for that signal to shut it
down and be able to get back to Helio so
we can stop all the bad guys and I help
our friend handsome Jack who is actually
a friend and a nice guy in this game so
this is ice so we've got one of a new
enemies why did you kill it oh it didn't
even attack you this game has moral
choices like do you shoot a thing or do
you not if you don't then the game
doesn't actually but if you doing you
don't get Luke yeah if you don't
actually flame again but yeah these are
Craig guns one of our new enemies you'll
notice something cool here when this
bigger one dies C splits up into smaller
ones pop-out which is kind of cool
yeah you also popped a cryo vine xyn
which is what froze him Oh what's this
gun oh it's a laser and it's different
to the one we saw before how well this
one has a TDI barrel which essentially
gives it a splitter beam which is
essentially a laser shotgun and I don't
really need to say much more than that I
don't think laser shotgun Steven shut up
a plot thing is happening
people with that so enthrall that's a
laser bigger than the laser beam
why doesn't jack have his mask ass in
that bag
you gotta hurry we gotta see Leo
speakers night it's all over I find out
wearing that was Helios that's the place
we're trying to get back to you that's
the space station that shot a bunch of
stuff at you in Borderlands 2 jack was
helping builder at the beginning of this
game when he hired you to uncover a
vault and open it and then you got
attacked by some other dudes notice
Wilhelm is really fast at reloading that
laser gun because Chris invested in the
skill that makes him better with laser
guns
I cannot again Duran did okay
this is pea pot he's just a sidequest
character he's fun one of them Oh what's
going on Greg groans this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me destroy
them gotta slam going on there and you
will have seen that the slam actually
did shock damage that's one of the
things that those kids can do as kids
are one of our new pieces of gear it
does stuff like give you your oxygen
supply some other buffs and it allows
you to slam and you can get ours kits
that change your slam into different
elements so real home right now
obviously has a shock one which is
really handy so if you've got all your
weapons of one type and your sort of one
coverage of a different element you can
use your rods kit to get that element
into your arsenal Chris should uses a
action see I want to see what's insane
yeah do that
say wolf cruising around firings is
attempts
you did it Chris
and the cool thing you can do with
orphan st. as well is if you sort of
clear clear all the enemies often
they've still got duration left you can
hold down the action scroll button to
recall them and get some of the cooldown
refunded so since it's like a long
duration long cooldown action skill you
don't need to stress too much about
activating it at the wrong time since
you've always got that option to recall
them so there's a geyser and err geysers
which refills all your oz up to full
even though you can run out of oxygen in
this game hey it doesn't happen very
often at all because there's so many
ways to get more oxygen and these drop
it's there geysers all around the map
and even if you do run a Vox Jimmy the
health penalty for it is so small
basically oxygen runs out just to be a
resource that balances out how often you
can double jump and do Slams because
those are really powerful maneuvers and
just wanting to be able to do that all
the time without anything else Michael
Jordan there's not a way to go after
this thing what's this thing steel this
is an oxygen generator so you can see as
it comes on this derm appears and in
this whole area now has oxygen in it
the other cool thing with this is
there's some other effects that occur
whether you're in or outside atmosphere
the obvious one is a incendiary weapon
so you can't catch on fire if you're in
a vacuum because there's no oxygen today
and that can work two ways so if you've
got a cool incendiary weapon you sort of
want to be in the atmosphere to ignite
people but if you've got enemies trying
to set you on fire you might want to
switch it off so that they can't set you
on fire
and you see we've just got the Vengeance
cannon popping out because your shield
went down so if we start shooting you'll
see all the big fire blasts it does it's
kind of destructive
and so I think we just saw someone
talking to us you want to tell us who
that was infinite that was red belly red
belly is the leader of this group of
scabs and he is parked right in front of
that big-ass satellite dish that is
sending the jamming signal up to Helios
so we're gonna have to fight our way
past red belly and stop the jamming
signal because we want to save the world
because we're the good guys in quotation
marks because even though we're actually
working to save a bunch of innocent
people by the time for lines to comes
around most of these characters are
bosses so the question is Stephen are we
heroes or is everybody just villains
what is it which is it how does a
reality work talk to me everyone
everyone's a hero
incorrect everyone is the worst aunty
heroes are fun so Chris died yeah he
managed to kill all the enemies and then
die yeah which is impressive in its own
way more person that he just played like
a good player and survived so we're
gonna watch him trudge back but look at
that skybox with those colors not like
up like that I meant like I was talking
to the viewer god I hate you
but not me for Claire no not you
no I like you
welcome to calm society I think that's
that makes me Chuck a little every time
that like you know you're stealing that
money instead or nothing you're staying
the money but that in a no oxygen
environment the Saints just pop off
entirely they don't just open normally
so we saw a robot bunch of decompressor
ization yeah I would pressurize my money
too
yeah doesn't so he is good at punching
things to stun them with that awesome
robot punch it knocks the enemy's back
and does a lot of explosive damage to
them so you can actually use it to try
to stun enemies that are doing a
buttload of damage into you to basically
stop shooting he's flying to meet his
creator yeah usually like in Borderlands
2 your answer to what happens when I
should sit when I take damage is well
you probably take cover in this game
because you have so many mobility
options it seems as if you would have
the ability to freeze things or to punch
things and stun them that way or to slam
and knock them back that way
or to shoot a cryo barrel next to a
abandoned and then shatter him to do a
bunch of pieces and then get shot from
the behind because you're not actually
paying attention to what's going on I'm
Chris failure yeah it's a good point you
make about the cover and stuff like with
the low gravity cover you sort of you
are completely differently because if
there's an enemy hiding behind a cover
you can be like well I don't really care
I can just jump up into the sky and drop
a rocket on your head but it's my word
but conversely like if you're hiding
behind cover the enemies the enemies
have jetpacks and stuff as well so
they're going to be coming at you from
above - so you can't feel she's just
suicide yeah you know you're not gonna
kill him you're gonna want to use your
lasers Chris because you SPECT into a
scale that gives you more laser damage
and use Wolfenstein and I should be
playing you're the worst
this game is Todd apparently yeah this
is Goldeneye 64 if you're just joining
us playthrough - yep oh yeah we're on
true vault hunter months of the game
actually is harder generally so Chris
has like houses so if you're a first
time play like Chris didn't play
playthrough - there your work that we're
off to a good start so yeah now start
sprinting around make sure your some of
your Sprint's going on and then
he's shooting at him you actually may
want to take to recovery now even I said
this isn't necessarily game I think
every may want to surgery st. has some
time to shooting a wall big badass guys
okay your vengeance cannon did a couple
shots on the cool thing there was ran
wolf is taking a lot of the aggro off
you because it's good at annoying the
enemies right you do this Chris you
could do it green big fist finish
you did it you became a man today hey
what's that what's that that's a moon
stone what's a moon stone that's one of
our new currencies in Borderlands the
pre-sequel it it sort of has a similar
role as iridium dude in Borderlands 2
but canonically doesn't make sense that
a reading would be on the planet this
time because iridium didn't show up to
war Lance - what's that all about
yeah that just makes sense right yeah
yeah but there's also some new things
that moon stones will be used for which
we're not talking about just yet but
yeah there's definitely gonna be some
more varied uses than just iridium Chris
just took a mean a turtle shield which
reduces maximum health by almost 50% I'm
sure this is going to work out really
well
st. is secretly crying
all right so we're getting closer to the
signal is here
taking as legendary shotgun so you may
have noticed earlier but he if you ever
shoot a scab in the head when they have
one of those on oxygen helmets on you oh
my god you must pull yourself up the
connector overnight it will pop their
oxygen helmet and they'll begin to a 68
which means a couple things one they
will take some dot damage damage up
return rabbit and two they will
reparative time stop attacking us that
you busy on our house and three they
look like here they look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger at the end of Total
Recall nice setup yes well you almost
missed it again I always I was
absolutely a hundred cent would have
missed mentioning Total Recall again for
the fourth time
nice that was good stuff that was cool I
think you actually blew up a cryo barrel
as well yeah which is why you're now
frozen and dying that's alright just
kill a guy it's easy the Academy have
super evening moonstruck yeah moonstruck
is that playthrough two version of the
lunatics alright okay they're pretty
tough keep forgetting when I'm playing
and the cool thing about the loonatics
which are kind of like the psychos in
Borderlands 2 is oh my god I just got
lunatics really I just got the joke holy
[ __ ]
oh god dammit sorry what were you saying
I was going to talk about their jetpacks
but I don't really know I had go ahead
well with with the moon environment
being a sort of a different pace of
gameplay this those the lunatics have
adapted to that too and they actually
have little booster packs where they
will do this flying dash towards you so
they're not quite as predictable as the
psychos in bottle answer and I'll sort
of be in your face a bit quicker
fixation so much a situation as you pop
all those comets
another badass let's see if Christian
will take this one out on his first go
that's from the room who thinks he's
gonna do it Jennifer
you think he's gonna do it that's one
move vs Oh Jennifer is gonna be so wrong
I think symbols matters okay I mean well
not yet don't put your faith in Chris
but you paid them off and say yeah I do
one that Murphy night oh god I love the
knock back from the stun it's it's are
from the slam such a nice little
disruption in combat that's a really
nice element of utility to it it's not
just a damaged thing yeah it's good
against like lunatics because you can
say hey get away from me I don't want
you to shoot in the head Chris him in
the head you want crits Oh Jennifer's
face with Miss plays God is dead and
we're alone Chris Bailey reporter Lance
pre-sequel
I don't know so yeah this was just a
little bit of Borderlands the pre-sequel
I'm Anthony Burch I'm Steve Amanda Jones
my brother buddy point